and a warning this interview has a
description of how jack and paul were
killed which people may find distressing
claire
first up thanks for coming to talk to us
today and telling us your story
i want to ask you about the events that
led you here your campaign to try and
better protect children from domestic
abusers but but let's start with your
boys jack and paul
what were they like
they were the typical
boys um
very
outgoing confident
it's funny you you bring them up both
exactly the same and yet they're so
different jack was
a lot more caring um a lot quieter
paul was cheeky
full of fun full of energy
jack was a musician
he
loved music it ran through his veins
like
water down a stream and he played the
trumpet
and until he started playing the trumpet
he was quite a
introvert quite quiet boy yeah but
playing the trumpet absolutely changed
his life yeah he found that it was okay
to try to do something and
it's okay to fail
paul
was always trying to be like his brother
paul was a runner he was a sprinter
in fact i think he could run before he
could walk
and when you saw him run
it set him free
150 was his favorite
distance
and he loved the glamour of the track
but he used to light up from inside and
he'd say whatever's happening at home
on that track nothing can catch me
nothing can touch me and claire your
boys would have been jack would have
been 20 now and paul would have been 17
and do you sort of imagine it that
jack might have been a musician and paul
might have been a sort of sprinter
yeah their futures were taken away from
them and
it's really an open wound that i keep
picking but it's bleeding anyway
i see his friends and
i saw one of jack's friends the other
day and he's got a beard and it's
a case of that's what jack could look
like now um
all the
all the marks the proms
learning to drive
leaving school
going to university that could have been
them and that should have been them
can i go back to if it's all right with
you
to your experience and and the events
leading up to you your boys
losing your boys
you met the boy's father when you were
25 i think
um did you notice any red flags about
him back then or did he woo you and
was a very loving partner
back when i met him there were no
mention of domestic abuse
the term love bombing
he sent a rose to my works every day for
three weeks until i said i'd go out with
him okay there was something i didn't
like about him and i'd said that i
wouldn't go out with him but
you know after three weeks you kind of
feel
sort of a little bit special maybe a
little bit more interesting than
normal yeah now i would say to any young
person that that's actually love bombing
and you're being conditioned
to be loved what's coercive it's a bit
controlling
you left
your ex-husband
after 16 years that must have felt
like a relief was it for you
well to be honest that's when the danger
escalated so it wasn't really for you as
well for all of us okay um
because that's when he lost control
right
when of you
yeah and the boys
because the boys didn't want to see him
but as you said
actually the situation deteriorated
because
the boys had
unsupervised visitation with their
father even though you fought that
in the court can you just explain to
viewers what happened
so in the july i was forced
to go to court and begin residency order
proceedings against him
and that's when
the fear and oppression just carried on
he was allowed to
intimidate me in the court i had to sit
in the sim
waiting area
and he was sat just across from me
and what people don't realize about
family courts is they're not protected
like a magistrate's in a crown court
and in those courtrooms
perpetrators are allowed to cross
question
their victims
and even though he had a barrister there
he hurled insult after insult across
that room it was just a board room i was
just four seats away from him and in the
second court hearing he actually went
for me so we had to move away from the
doorway
and when we got into the courtroom
the judge
said that
even though he's shown and displayed
this aggressive behavior
he still could have five hours
unsupervised access
to his children a week
so the boys went back
was it to your house
yes
we'd only been divorced two weeks
by the 22nd of october
and uh
when i walked in
call it instinct call it
worry i always worried
about the boys i said the phones are on
the table they need the phones every
time they go to see the dad
and she said he was like picking them up
today
so
i was actually debating about going down
there and and giving them the phones and
if i had done i'd have been able to go
in and get them
that haunts me to this day
but instead
i had my tea and it could only have been
15 minutes
and the doorbell rang
and for some reason i didn't want to
answer it
call it an instinct call it
a warning
and when i opened the door
there was a local police officer
and he stepped back under the light
and i looked at his face
and the first thing i said was what has
he done
now i live in a small village he knew
jack and paul i'd pass them at school
i'd say to him morning
he'd say
morning
and the look on his face i knew you knew
and i said what has he done
and he said there's been an incident
and you need to come with me now the
boys have been taken to sheffield
children's hospital
so i got in the car
and we traveled
at about 100 miles an hour to
sheffield children's hospital
and he pulled into the square where the
resource rooms are
and he said go
go go
so i ran in and the first thing i saw
was
a medic doing cpr on paul and paul
you're not who's there nine you're nine
year old
and i just remember watching him
being bounced off the bed with the force
of the
cpr's not nice to see or do
and uh
i was dragged literally into a room
because i was just ready to run across
to him
and
a doctor came to me
and i could see with his face
and he said to me are you
their mum
i said yes
and
he said
i'm very sorry but we're going to let
him go now in your arms
and i said what do you mean go
and he said there's nothing more we can
do so i ran through with him
and i just scooped him up into my arms
and when people say the light goes out
of people's eyes you don't believe it
till you see it
and these beautiful blue eyes just
looked at me and they turned gray
and they just looked as if they were
looking through me
and i said to him
come on paul you can't leave
don't do this
stay
but he'd gone and the nurse
closed his eyes and i was holding on to
him so tightly
and my tears were wet in his hair
and i just sat rocking him
and i went screaming because i couldn't
talk the pain
was just so intense
there was nothing yeah just this pain
and this love
and i said to him
that i loved him
and i promised him
that no other child
would be hurt
by a parent or an adult
and i was still holding him tightly
and
the medics came and said you have to let
him go now he's a crime scene
and there were just the wrong words to
say because he wasn't a crime scene he
was yeah yeah my son my cheeky yeah full
of energy running
son that i just dropped off at school
yeah nine hours earlier and he looked
perfect he just had a scratch
down his nose and that was from where
jack had pulled him he pulled him across
the attic
and uh he just looked like he was
sleeping
and i said to the nurse
don't leave him on his own he's only
nine
and the nurse said no i'll i'll sit with
him
and then
i went over to jack
and he was still fighting at this point
and they turned around and said to me
you've got a choice now
we're taking jack to manchester
so you either stay and sit with paul
or you go with jack
to manchester
it was the furthest they'd ever been
apart as brothers
they'd never spent a night apart they'd
never spent more than a few hours apart
we
we got to manchester
and uh
jack held on for five days it was 56
burnt
and details were coming out slow but
sure about what actually happened so
that they could piece it
together
and they worked out that um
he'd actually barricaded the property
and trapped jack and paul in the attic
he was found in one corner of the attic
and jack had tried to escape and when
paul fell
he went back for his brother and he gave
his hand in the darkness to his brother
and he used his own strength
to pull his brother
to the hatchway
and for five days
the hospital
said i had to talk about paul as if he
was alive
because jack believed he'd saved his
brother
and jack was
only sedated he wasn't in a coma he was
sedated for the pain but he must have
been a lot of pain
and
if he knew that
paul hadn't made it it would affect his
recovery yes
so for five days i sat at his bedside
and
you could tell what he could hear
because every time i spoke to him
his heart monitor went right down
he just calmed him down like hearing his
mum
just calmed him
and then on the monday
which was his
third operation
it wasn't going well
and um
he'd come out and he was in recovery but
he wasn't recovering
and this nurse came flying down the
corridor
and i just ran after her she didn't even
have to say anything
and they started cpr because with burns
victims
the potassium levels in your blood build
up
and the potassium stops your heart
right okay
and
jack's potassium levels was too high so
he just went systolic so his heart
stopped
and again i watched them
perform cpr on him
i knew the longer that they were doing
cpr and god they tried they tried
that less of
jack would have come back
and
if he hadn't been able to place trumpet
if he hadn't been that gentle boy who
had a
heart and courage of a lion
then who were i bringing him back for
they fought and fought
and again they turned to me with that
look in the face
and they said we're gonna have to call
it
and i scooped him up
in my arms
i promised him
i said to him that
no more children
should have to be killed by a parent
no other child should have to say to a
fireman and a doctor and a police
officer
that their dad had hurt them and they'd
done it on purpose
and no more parents would have to end up
like me
just existing just living not even
living
nobody should have to
hold their children in their arms as
they die
and
their lives were
taken because the court said they could
i
did everything by the book
played by the rules
i told
the court in my application
back in july that he was capable of
killing the boys
cafcass
i told them not to see him
on their own because when he heard
something he didn't like
then he got aggressive
i told social services the same
kafkas ignored that
and on the monday before the wednesday
she had an interview with him in her
office
and
when she terminated the
interview he barricaded her in the
office and refused to let her leave the
room
that was never reported that was never
acted on
and had i known that on the wednesday
then i would have quite happily gone to
jail
rather than let them
go on that visit
and jack and paul made 19 children
murdered at the hands of a known
perpetrator of domestic abuse
and now we're up to 43 children
and it's not even been 10 years
and i promised both of them that they
would be the last
tell me what your
your goal is in terms of the next piece
of legislation that you feel is
necessary to better protect children
there's a piece of legislation called
practice 12j right and it's practice
direction for children that are
suffering abuse
now i can hear people screaming it now
if we have to have legislation to
protect children who are going through
abuse
why not just stop the
presumption of contact in the first
place
this
small piece of legislation underneath
the children's act
was brought in
around parental access yes to children
and in this
legislation it says it's in the child's
best interest
to see both
parents now this obviously needs
changing too
only if it's in the child's best
interests and it's safe to do so
because practice 12j
is what
social services cafcass and judges
make their rulings yeah
now
there's so much made about parental
rights
but there's this deafening silence when
it comes to children's rights
and every child's right
is to be safe and loved
and protected
one final question for you
claire
the way you talk about them
it feels to me like they're still with
you they're very much still with you you
feel that to you that they are
perched upon your shoulders
the day that i don't talk about them the
day that i don't feel them
that's the day that they die
and i will keep talking about them
and i will challenge every court in this
land i'll challenge every
lord every lady every baroness every
baronet
every prime minister
i will challenge them all
to say that they have done the best that
they can to keep every child in this
country safe
and not one of them can look at me in
the face and say that
and i will carry on asking the awkward
questions i will ask people to sign the
petition
i will ask them to sign the campaign and
i will take it back through courts again
and i'll take it to the house of lords
again
because since they ruled
that practice direction 12j didn't need
looking at
more children have died
more
and they could have made a difference to
those children
and they have to be held accountable
for that
and so far nobody is
so i'm going to carry on
even though it rips my heart into every
day
because
they would have stood up and done the
same
for me
and
that's why
i carry on
in their names
well claire thank you it felt like a
real privilege that you shared your
story with me
and told me about your boys and told us
about your campaign so thank you so much
i'm really grateful i know that
that's not easy um thanks for telling it
thank you